do you have advice for young people
today in high school in college of how
to
live a life
as uh non-linear and as successful as
yours
a life that could be uh they could be
proud of well that's that's a super
compliment i'm humbled by that actually
i i would say
a life they can be proud of honestly one
thing i've said to people is
first um find people you love and care
about them like family matters to me a
lot and family means people you love and
have committed to
right so it can be whatever you you mean
by that but it's it you need to have a
foundation
uh so find people you love and want to
commit to and do that
um because it anchors you in a way that
nothing else can
right and then
and then you find other things and then
kind of from out there you find other
kinds of things you can commit to
whether it's ideas or or people or
groups of people
um so you know especially in high school
i would say don't settle on what you
think you know
right
give yourself 10 years
to think about the world like there's i
see a lot of high school students who
seem to know everything already
i i think i did too i think it's maybe
natural but
but recognize that
the things you care about you might
change your perspective over time
i certainly have over time as senator
you know i was really passionate about
one specific thing and i was kind of
softened you know i was a big um i
didn't like the federal reserve right
and
there's still we can have a longer
conversation about monetary policy and
finances but
but
i'm a little more uh nuanced in my in my
perspective at this point
um
but you know that's that's one area
where you learn about someone going i
want to attack it you know
build don't destroy
like build like someone so often the
tendency is to not like something they
want to go attack it
build something build something to
replace it yeah build up you know
attract people to your new thing
you'll get you'll be far more far better
right you don't need to destroy
something to build something else um so
that's i guess generally
uh and then you know definitely
uh like curiosity you know follow your
curiosity
and and let it um
don't just follow the money
and all that like you said is grounded
in um
family friendship and ultimately love
yes
which is uh
a great way to end it travis you're one
of the most impactful people in the
engineering computer science in the
human world so i truly appreciate
everything you've done
and i really appreciate that you would
spend your valuable time with me it was
an honor it was a real pleasure for me i
appreciate that
you